I'm Ray Britton and I'm the Scoutmaster with Troop 42 in Oak Ridge, Tennessee.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Keep up the good work, Clark.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
The newest thing coming out right now: the cutting edge. Have you seen these yet?
I'm talking about the invisible scout patch.
No, I've seen them and they're really not much to look at.
Hey, this is podcast number 252..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag. Wow, we got a few here.
Let's see. Tony Wilson is the Scoutmaster of Troop 86 in Panoli, California.
He said I wanted to take a minute and say thank you.
I'm the new Scoutmaster of my twin son's troop.
I started looking into your app and Facebook excerpts on a regular basis
And I'm finding a lot of helpful items and ideas.
I also got a copy of your new book, and that would be so far, so good.
If you don't have the book yet, folks, it's easy to get.
It's on Amazon and you can also get it through the website at scoutmastercgcom.
After a rough day, I sat back with the book.
I read it from cover to cover and I really enjoyed it.
It makes me feel better about being the Scoutmaster and the direction of our troop.
I already started trying some of the things mentioned in the first few chapters
that I read on the web this past fall.
Thank you for your insight into this new adventure in my life
and the scouting careers of all the Scouts in Troop 86..
Well, thank you, Tony. Thanks for getting in touch.
I'm glad you're finding what we're doing useful.
I heard from Korra who said: I'm one of those crazy people who listen to your podcast
when I am working. quote unquote, basically over and over again in the background.
Thank you for all you do.
Hey, thank you, Korra. Get back to work now, okay?
William Colling-Bankston is the Scoutmaster of Troop 187 in Fairfax, Virginia.
He said I recently started listening to the podcast and I really appreciate your work.
You've convinced me how important it is to be thoroughly familiar
with the guides to advancement, safe scouting, awards and insignia, et cetera.
Do you know if there are any audio versions of these guides available?
Again, thanks for your efforts.
I know our unit is providing a better program because of resources like scoutmastercgcom.
Well, thank you, William.
I really don't know of an audio version of those guides.
I think an audio version may be kind of difficult to listen to.
What you want is: you want the guide in a PDF version
or an electronic version on your mobile device
so that you can get right into it and you can search it
and you can find the information that you want quickly.
That's what I would suggest, better than an audio version. I think
Eric Ball is the Scoutmaster for the 7th Markham Scouts in Ontario, Canada,
And he said: I just learned about your site this fall
via posters made from several of your infographics
posted on the mess hall wall of our fall camp.
I've added your podcast to my daily commute
and I'm gradually working my way backwards through them.
Well, thank you so much, Eric.
I knew it was worth time making those infographics.
How about that?
We had a couple of live chats this past week.
If you keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed,
you will see notices when there's a live chat going on
at scoutmastercgcom.
Usually it's a weekday morning
And we had a number of folks check in.
Thank you, Dale and John and Dennis and George
and Kendall and Steve and Randy
and Dave for checking in with me this week.
Like I said, keep an eye on the Facebook feed
and the Twitter feed for when we'll be on
with a live chat at scoutmastercgcom.
Let me take a moment to say this:
If you're a regular reader and listener
and the resources we've created are helping you,
you can return the favor by becoming
a scoutmastercgcom backer.
The funds we get from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing all of the stuff
that we publish, keeping those resources
accessible to scouts all over the world.
It's easy to do.
All you have to do is go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page
and you can choose any level of support,
and some of those levels entitle you to premiums
like autographed copies of my books.
So let me take a moment to personally thank
Brad Ayers, Greg Kennedy and Jim Moore,
who all became backers since our last podcast.
Go to scoutmastercgcom
and become a backer this week, and I'll be sure
to thank you during our next podcast.
Well, this week I have email questions to answer.
I have one, two, three, four of them,
and that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started. shall we
E-mail? that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of your e-mails.
We're going to begin with an e-mail
in which I will hold the sender anonymous
and the reason will be clear as soon as I get started here.
An issue surfaced in my troop
and it's explained in this e-mail I received from a parent.
Our son has started counseling.
His teachers recommended this
because they're worried about his anxiety levels.
They've also recommended he needed additional help
with a couple of other things.
So he already feels a little bit like
the world is conspiring against him.
He's having an issue with scouts.
He's very offended by the language
used by some of the scouts in the troop.
To be fair, it probably isn't anything
he hasn't heard coming out of my mouth
on many occasions, but coming from his peers
it's disturbing him.
He's also feeling a little ostracized
and left out because he doesn't join in
with the bad language and therefore
he's on the outside looking in.
I think the main thing is that he said
that because of this
this is no longer fun anymore.
He's talked about changing troops
and I'm not sure that would be the answer.
I can't say one troop would be better
at suppressing language than the other.
I know what I heard when I was a scout.
When my wife asked me if I ever felt ostracized
by my Boy Scout troop,
I replied with a resounding yes.
So that was the message from the parent,
and the person who sent me this question
went on to say:
should the conference be helpful?
Should adults be more involved
in disciplining inappropriate behavior,
even if we don't witness it?
Are we letting the inmates run the asylum?
I'm at a loss right now and I could use some advice.
If you have any thoughts,
I would appreciate you sharing them.
I'm concerned about the use of foul language
in my troop, but I'm not sure to the extent of it.
I'm not sure about the anxiety issue.
Perhaps this scout is a special case.
We've been very successful
in having a youth-led experience
and the scouting question is a fairly new scout
who joined last spring.
Well, let's see if we can sort this out a little bit.
Most of the time, if one scout
is complaining about the behavior of other scouts
and nobody else seems to be bothered about it,
then the likelihood that it has more to do with the scout
or the parent who's complaining
than the seriousness of the problem.
Now, naturally,
I would never say that foul language is good,
but it's almost always not
an absolute serious problem.
You know, while I'm saying that
it's not often a serious problem,
it's a problem and it should be addressed-
and I should be addressed directly
and I would make it the subject of a scout master minute.
I would talk to my patrol leader's counsel about it.
I would say that this is a concern
that we need to deal with
and you guys need to work on
your observance of the Scout Oath and Law
as far as these matters are concerned.
I wouldn't necessarily go about
dictating this to them
as much as encouraging them
to think about it and to empathize
with people who might be offended by that kind of language
and whether or not they think that is proper
in the context of what they're doing as scouts.
Get them thinking, Get them working on it,
Get them empathizing with one another,
Get them thinking about the Scout Oath and Law.
It's actually a very good opportunity
to do just that
and that's the way we work with
these types of issues in a scout troop.
The scout you're talking about
sounds very familiar to me.
He's a little fragile, He's a little frightened,
He's younger, He's looking for some reassurance
and for some reason the foul language
is something he's perseverating on.
but this may be due to the other anxieties
that he's experiencing,
and it can get very complicated
If he doesn't make friends easily
and he has feelings of ostracism.
he's finding things difficult
Now. this won't last forever.
I found this is a pretty common thing
that happened with boys.
They feel like outsiders
and that kind of fuels their fears
of being ostracized
and they get defensive and sensitive
to lots of things
and then their peers react to that
and that reaction supports their fears
and the cycle just kind of keeps on going.
but, like I said, happily
a lot of this fades as they get a little bit older.
Now it can make parents
absolutely crazy, and I understand,
because your child is in distress
and they're trying to figure out
what the heck is going on.
and between the ages of 11 and 14,
most of the scouts that I have worked with
are going to have done this,
what I call going on the dark side
of the moon- for a while.
It could be a number of months,
It could be a year or so,
but they just seem to be out of the range of communication.
They're in their own chaotic world,
blindly pushing buttons,
lashing out at things,
trying to figure things out,
and that can make them very anxious,
it can make them kind of surly and mean,
it can make them emotional and unpredictable.
they act out in all kinds of ways,
and some of them can be dangerous
and negative, and some of them can be
like what you're experiencing,
with just a lot of anxiety
and feelings of ostracism involved.
they're looking for consistency
and constancy in the world.
they're figuring out how the world works.
now, if the adults get all reactive
to the anxiety
or to the bad behavior
or they try to affect those behaviors
with a change in circumstances,
things are going to become even more unsettled.
if parents and scouts will hold the line,
stick to their word
and remain as consistent as possible,
you're showing your sons
and your scouts
that there is some peace and order
in at least some aspect of their lives,
that they can step out of that
chaotic life that they're experiencing
onto some solid ground.
they won't understand this very much,
but they will ultimately appreciate it.
so what does a scouter
or a parent do?
well, as a parent,
I'd pretty much require some
highly interactive social activity
like scouts right.
if the child fights me on that-
and they can do that sometimes very dramatically-
as a parent
I would be
likely to push back a little bit
and require this of them.
now. that's very general advice
and any parent who's faced
with a difficulty like this.
I would want some reassurance
strategy
from the counselors that the child is talking to
and be prepared
for some rocky times.
but this is what I would suggest.
as a scouter:
I would address the basic
anxiety and insecurity
and the fragility by being as supportive
and encouraging as possible.
now you can also enlist your older scouts
in this.
I've had many a quiet word with an older scout
asking them to take notice of something positive
or to befriend them
or to help them out,
and usually that older scout
that I'm talking to
has been through exactly the same kind of thing
where they were anxious,
where they felt ostracized
when they were younger.
I have seen this literally hundreds of times
now. parents
are usually going through this for the first time
and it can really knock them for a loop.
I understand
any boy will have his moments
and some can be more dramatic
than others.
some have complications
like learning differences
or physical limitations,
but just about every single one of them
makes it through just fine.
you have to be consistent.
this is no new advice.
you have to be consistent
and your child is in distress
and I know how painful that is,
but they're all going to be in
distress of one kind
or another at this age
and they're going to get on the other side of it.
they're going to be just fine.
every one of the scouts that we're working with,
every young person
is a special case.
they all need different things
in different measures.
there are no normal scouts-
I've never met one.
there are no normal children-
half the fun of our work
is sorting out how to deal
in a good place to be able to do that.
I heard from James,
who had this to say:
along with being a scout master,
I'm also a dive instructor.
I read an article on a dive instructor
who was training scouts
in which one of the scouts unfortunately died
during the training
and the parents were suing the instructor.
I haven't heard you talk about anything
as to what liabilities
a scouter can incur
when they take scouts on outings.
if a scout is injured,
is there civil liability protection
for scouts?
if parents decide to sue a scouter,
what happens?
well, James, you haven't heard me discuss legal liability
very much because I'm far
from being an expert in that sort of thing,
but you hear me talking about safety a lot
and I like to feel pretty experienced
with safety
so far as scouting goes.
and, of course, the most important
thing is being safe.
now the BSA
does provide general liability insurance
coverage. that explains this way
and I'll link to what I'm about to
read here in the post
that contains this podcast.
we have what's called comprehensive general
liability insurance
and this is what the BSA says.
registered volunteers
are provided primary coverage
through the BSA general liability program.
BSA general
liability policy provides
public coverage for a bodily injury
or property damage claim
that is made and arises out of an official
scouting activity.
the guide to safe scouting contains
a listing of unauthorized
and restricted activities.
unauthorized activities are not considered
official scouting activities.
volunteers,
registered and unregistered
units, chartered organizations
and local councils
are jeopardizing insurance coverage for themselves
and for our organization by engaging
in unauthorized activities.
please do not put yourself at risk.
so the short answer is:
if a scout in our care is injured,
we're covered.
there is a caveat in what I read
talking about official scout activities,
and I'm not going to try and delve
into specifics on that,
because it's all dealt with
in the guide to safe scouting,
something that you should have a copy of
and that you should review
on a regular basis to make sure
that you're running a safe program.
now anybody can initiate a civil case
against anybody else.
pretty much
it's not that difficult to do
so. if a parent wants to sue you,
they probably can.
now, I don't have personal knowledge
of any cases when this has happened,
so for me
this is kind of a theoretical situation.
but when it comes to managing
risk,
the first thing on my mind
is my personal liability
and the foremost thing on my mind
is the safety of my scouts.
I am not thinking about
well, we better not do that
because somebody might sue me.
no, I'm thinking about:
is this a safe thing to do?
would a reasonable person do this?
is it in accordance with the guide to safe scouting?
am I following the sweet 16
of BSA safety?
am I keeping my scouts safe?
I go into them now, but I've been in a couple
of really harrowing situations
in the wilderness that have made me
very cautious about following
the rules,
and that is what's
most important to do
now. there have been a handful of times-
maybe three or four
over the past 30 years when a scout
in my care needed medical attention
for an injury
above and beyond
what we would render as first aid,
and I think that's a pretty good record.
I attribute it to following the rules
and being aware of the dangers
and safety is really pretty simple.
it's what you don't know.
you don't know.
that usually causes the problem
and most people, if they're dealing with risky situations,
will develop a sense
of when we're approaching dangerous territory,
metaphorically,
and we stop.
we're cautious,
we try and figure out what's happening
before we just go barging on ahead.
and if you get anything out of this,
the whole idea is
instilling appreciation
for managing risks and keeping your
scouts safe. I wouldn't lose any sleep
over the fear of being sued
and I wouldn't be anything less
than vigilant about keeping scouts
safe. I feel
I'm a little over cautious from time to time,
but I get over it.
having a good understanding
of the guide to safe scouting
and reviewing them
on a regular basis
is the best insurance
that you're going to have.
Eric Byrd is an assistant scout master
for Troop 33
in Laurel Mississippi
and he wrote in to say this.
I recently found your podcast
and have greatly enjoyed listening
to the new and archived editions.
I have a question.
I'm sure you've addressed it on the podcast,
but I've got to come across it
in advance for your time.
well, Eric, I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast.
cell phones-
wow, we haven't talked about that in a while.
I'll tell you.
when scouts first started carrying cell phones
routinely-
and I guess maybe what is that
10 years or so ago-
they were a brand new challenge for us as
scouts, and there's all kinds of mischief
you can get up to with a cell phone
and man. we tried lots
of different permutations of this
and I struggled with the whole way
of managing them for a long time,
and after
I'd been doing that for a few years-
and, by the way, I never
really came up with a good way to manage them
other than saying no, you can't have them
at all,
and that never worked-
I noticed that one or two things happened
in the intervening years.
like I said, there was this time
where cell phones started
showing up and then we had this
difficult period where we were trying to manage them
and figure out what to do,
and during that time
a couple of things happened.
either cell phones didn't bother me all that much anymore
because all the problems I
thought they would create never really came
into being-
you know,
I never really had a whole lot of trouble with them-
or cell phones
became so much a part of the background of our lives
that I just stopped noticing them very much,
and the scouts
don't really notice them all that much.
they use them reasonably
responsibly and they don't
cause much, if any, difficulty
with them.
so I don't really have a policy.
one way or the other,
our scouts carry their cell phones everywhere
and all as I ask is that
in every other situation that they carry them-
whether it's at school,
whether it's with their family,
whatever is that- they're using them
respectfully and courteously,
causing disruption to what they're doing,
and this seems to work pretty well.
it doesn't always work,
but you know, it's kind of like
if you're going to tell scouts not to talk
while you're talking. how well does that work?
they do it,
but with a little reminder
they'll be respectful and courteous.
it just seems to be
in the background of their lives
and it's part of all of our lives now.
so we've learned
to be more respectful and courteous
with the use of cell phones.
that's the best thing I can understand.
now. you can just imagine
our forebears,
the scouts of old, reacting
to similar things that came along over the past
when comic books started showing up.
well, there's no way
we're allowing comic books at camp
around a camping trip.
all the boys will do is sit there with the comic books
and then the electronic games
started showing up. oh my gosh,
we can't have those.
that recorder showed up before then.
and the boomboxes
and all this stuff comes along,
whether it's a comic book or a boombox
or electronic game or anything like that,
anything that is so ubiquitous
and is just a part of their daily lives.
you're not going to do very well
having a blanket disapproval of them
and not being able to
deal with them at all
and actually some of these influences.
we want our scouts to
work along with them and learn
to be respectful and courteous
and learn the difference between
being distracted
and paying attention.
in a prohibitive environment
where we just prohibit any of those influences,
we're not going to be able to do that
now. when it comes down to it,
we can make any number of rules and regulations
for what our scouts can
and can't bring to camp,
what they're going to do
while they're camping or with the troop,
but what we may not understand.
we add the need for us
to enforce and police the rule
and pretty soon that's where you spend all your time.
as I say often,
we have the scout oath
and the scout law.
those are the only things that we need.
we don't need any rules on top of that,
because once you start talking about the scout oath and law,
it covers everything,
and creating a whole lot of rules
on top of that
it's really a losing proposition.
so I heard back from Eric,
who said: I appreciate your advice.
I'll tell you this story.
near the end of a long hike a few years ago,
we were all exhausted and we stopped for a break
and my cell phone rang
and it was the parents of one of the scouts
who was on the hike
who calmly informed me
that she just heard from her son,
who had called on his cell phone
to tell her he was lost on the hike.
I assured her, of course,
that he was right there,
but as I looked around
I noticed he was not.
so I called him on his cell phone
and he was shortly reunited with us.
I told all the scouts
to leave their cell phones at home for the hike,
but thankfully he didn't listen to me
and he had his phone with him.
so hey,
that's an interesting story, Eric,
and I think it goes to the point.
there's actually quite a few positives
to having cell phones around,
and we've used them when we're camping
or hiking, to communicate
without it distracting from what's happening.
so far as the program goes,
Melissa
is a registered nurse
and a merit badge counselor for the first aid merit badge
in Ozark, Missouri,
and she got in touch to say this:
it's getting harder and harder
to get scouts to use
the actual first aid merit badge pamphlet
rather than worksheets.
I've had parents
and even scouts who should know better
tell me I'm out of line trying to make scouts
use a merit badge book
or to get the merit badge book
or to have anything to do at all
with the merit badge book.
I apparently am supposed to feed all of the
info to them on merit badge worksheets
and sign off on their blue card
after a tidy little four-hour merit badge class.
I've had parents
and scouts argue with me about making
first aid kits as listed in the merit badge
requirements. they just want me
to show them the stuff and what goes in the kits
and let that be done.
I honestly believe that worksheets
take the place of the merit badge book
and I've had scouts use the worksheets
and google the answers to fill it out.
then I have to show them in the merit badge
book that the correct information
is often quite different from that
that they found on the internet.
when I began teaching the merit badge,
I went and got the merit badge book
and I found the BSA has specific
information
that they want scouts to learn
as part of getting the badge,
specific focus that you don't get
in similar first aid courses.
and when it comes to the worksheets,
scouts can fill out the worksheets
with info from all kinds of sources
and demonstrate how to do a skill and so on,
but it may or may not meet
the requirements
the way they are written in the merit badge book.
what can I refer to
and or distribute to parents
and scouts that will back me up
when I try to get scouts to use
their first aid merit badge book?
well, Melissa, I certainly hear you
now. I haven't counseled many merit badges
in the past few years, but I do understand the situation.
I really don't like the way
workbooks and worksheets are used
and I don't like groups doing merit badges.
I've never really liked that
and there's plenty that I would change
if it was in my power to do so,
but it's not so
I don't want to complain.
but as far as officialdom,
backing up your approach,
there was a recent post on the
blog about worksheets
and you know the kind of difficulty
that they can cause,
which echoes exactly what you've told me here.
in addition to that, there's the training
that is offered to merit badge counselors.
that has some very specific things to say
about the relationship between a counselor
and a scout
and it has a lot to say about
specificity so far as
requirements and things go.
and I'll add that you know first aid merit badge.
there's some very, very specific things
that are part of the requirements
that may be open to
a little bit of interpretation.
so far as the medical community is involved,
there may be, you know,
several different ways of doing a particular
skill involved, but it's
hard to be mistaken as a counselor
when you go with what's in the merit badge book.
so, Melissa, I hope that helps,
and I did hear back from Melissa
and she said thanks.
it was awesome to hear back from you.
I'll keep on doing my best. thanks for the encouragement
on my website and I use the info a lot.
thanks for everything you do for scouts
well. thanks for being in touch, Melissa.
I do appreciate it.
now, if you're a regular listener to the podcast,
you're going to have heard this before,
but it's very, very important.
you need to make sure
that you're differentiating between
the official sources that I cite
and my advice.
our starting point are the official
things that our organizations
tell us,
the resources that they produce.
that's our starting point.
make sure you go and understand
them and read them
and review them on a regular basis.
I will have links to the ones
that I've cited here in this podcast.
that's where you begin.
I don't want you to take me at my word.
go to those resources
and make sure that they back up any advice
that I might give you
and if, like Melissa, you have a question
for me, you can get in touch
and we'll do that in just a moment.
hey, thanks for listening to this
250 second
edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
go and read the blog at
scoutmastercgcom, if you would,
and while you're there, you can subscribe
to the blog by email.
you can join the 4,000 other mobile
scouters who have the scoutmaster cg app
on their mobile devices,
and you can get that app on google play
or at the itunes app store.
you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media
outlets. join the 7500
people who like scoutmaster blog on facebook
tweet along with the chorus of 1200
tweeters on twitter.
pin the paltrartuna's pictures
with 1900 other prolific pinners
on pinterest and watch us
at scoutmastercg on youtube.
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive scoutmastercg
circle on google plus.
what's that you can't face? facebook?
twitter makes you better. you have no interest
in pinterest. you don't put the? u in youtube.
are you a minus when it comes to google plus?
well, that's alright, monkey,
zoom in to the late 90s and send me an email.
that's right. you can get in touch with me,
clarkgreen, with your comments
and questions and your wild ideas
at clark. at scoutmastercgcom,
it's c-l-a-r-k-e
at
scoutmastercgcom.
did you know that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast and all this other stuff are not official
publications of anybody in particular,
especially the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization?
they're not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America or any other scouting organization.
nope, it's just me.
I've got a microphone and a laptop and a way to
get online and I'm trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and have a little bit of fun
along the way, speaking of which,
here is our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why, thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone,
you.